okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p this
is so funny the Eggman called in and
left a voicemail basically saying i I'm
jealous that I have sour grapes that I'm
not a homeowner on the basis of a story
we did on the bonus show yesterday
saying hey homeownership isn't
necessarily all it's cracked up to be
and listen to the incredible attack from
the Eggman saying that's my view only
because I am NOT a homeowner take a
listen to this I did I think your take
on renting versus buying is such sour
grapes because you don't own a house
it's pretty much horse looked if you say
the return is only like two percent
after you subtract all those taxes and
property memorial all the repairs and
stuff who cares
you're making arguments that home
sellers aren't even trying to make okay
here's the deal Dave I bought a house
fifteen years ago I paid it off now I
bought another house when I sell this
house I get all that money back it's all
mine the whole house I paid for it's all
my money fifteen years of renting when
you move what do you get back from that
nothing I don't know if you know what it
feels like to get on your mower and cut
your lawn and then sit back and look at
it and have a cocktail or a glass of
wine and just see the property that you
own you might have to pay taxes on it
every every year but um Dave you're just
missing out we're not trying to make
money on our houses we're trying to get
our money back I'm poor white trash I
paid off the house in 15 years now when
I sell it all that money's mine I've
never had that kind of money before so
I'm discouraging people from buying a
house is very very silly you have to
take a risk to get ahead of life you'll
never get ahead in renting you always
want to be mobile and able to go from
place to place you're gonna be living
out of a backpack and a couple piece of
furniture get some roots man where you
own something you plant roots I also
have kids god damnit what's wrong with
you you're not a kid anymore have
children marry this woman get a house
with a yard get a lawnmower with a big
deck learn how to pick leaves and stuff
and teach your kid had to uh you know be
a good liberal shallow brother love you
guys oh man
man you know I don't even know how to
respond to this other than to say
everything he said is wrong I have been
involved in multiple real estate
transactions I do own a house it does
have a yard I do know about picking
weeds and mowing the lawn and all of
this stuff and what Eggman seems to be
missing is you know if anyone's out of
place with their comment Eggman's
talking about paying off a house in
fifteen years and it obviously being
more logical than renting Eggman lives
in rural upstate New York which is
extraordinarily inexpensive good luck
trying to pay off a house in 15 years in
Boston or in New York City or in San
Francisco and the point of the whole
story that we were talking about on the
bonus show was when you calculate how
much you made on a house if that's what
you're doing doesn't mean you have to
it's important to take out of that all
of the interest you pay down the
mortgage if you buy a house for $200,000
on a 15 year mortgage or even a 30 year
mortgage you're not actually paying
200,000 for it you're paying a multiple
of that because of all the interest and
you just have to account for that when
you consider your profit margin when you
sell you have to consider the cost of
the property taxes which you pay during
that time which you wouldn't if you're
renting so if anybody doesn't understand
I think it's the eggman number one
because I'm involved in multiple real
estate properties currently and I know
all about what the eggman is talking
about but most importantly he has a very
rural America centric view of how this
stuff works and all of the discussion we
had was that in many cases there are
advantages based on cost of living based
on age based on mobility desires and all
sorts of different things to not being a
homeowner I am a homeowner I understand
the pros I understand the cons but
please egg men very weak take because
you don't know what you're talking about
do I have anything else to say to the
egg man I guess not just Shalom and hope
hope you had a good Passover we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member become a patron we'll speak to
you then